because I because every man at some time
looks at their father and thanks oh I
could beat the [ __ ] out of this guy for
sure right now it happens to different
people different ages but everybody
looks at their dad at once like oh
[ __ ] tell me to take a bash again
yeah take a step for me around 16 right
keep going so that does write a first so
he was about 14 and he challenged me to
a fight
so the specials about that so I said to
him wouldn't it be funny if the end of
the special when they're running credits
it's me and you sparring right now it's
hilarious so the end credits yo first of
all you've seen my boy yeah
he's 6 3 he's all reach lanky and the
first time I stepped in my hand and I
know this is not good you're not your
hands not supposed to go back yeah when
my hand went back dude I saw his fist
coming and this is when I knew I'm like
I'm getting old because I saw his fist
coming and my head was like get out of
the way of that ain't working but my
body was like dude right punch her in
the face right in the face so I said to
him I said hey man take it easy
he goes I'll take it easy in the second
round oh wow how many rounds you guys
spar we did two the second two minutes
or three min two minutes I mean and it
was over with Wayne McCullough oh nice
and then we actually did one a box and
burn with Tony oh nice and but the
second round I started to wear out so at
about a minute and a half in the second
round I grabbed them and I whispered to
him because they're filming it yeah and
because with the headgear and the
mouthpiece is exhausting like I can't
get a brat foster phobic claustrophobic
right and I've never had I go hey man I
think I might throw up and just then he
goes whoo it hits me right in the
stomach
pearl bone no but it was the first time
I threw a real punch at so that this the
ending credits is you and your son's
going at it of him he just there's a
couple freeze frames and me eating
punches
I had to clubber Lang him once because
I'm stronger than old old man I picked
him up and threw him into the corner
because I was like I need a break boom
and just [ __ ] oh dude but it was wait
till your son I don't know if your son
will ever cuz your
he's gonna be bigger than me man yeah
he's a feisty one yeah he's a he's big
and I was it it's gonna happen like you
you start to feel your oats a little bit
I'm really testing my dad when I was 16
because it was like my senior year
everyone was taking the day off is like
ditch day hmm and I had is so much
school at the time where I didn't have
any more days I'd be in trouble so I
need my parents to call out so I'm like
oh I can't ditch Utley my dad to call I
don't even think you'd be an issue I got
you know hi Greg good grades all-star
football lacrosse all good man so I
didn't think of it and so me my dad are
talking I just go oh yeah dad and I'm
gonna forget it so you and I thought
it's really cool Mike and did you snap
at down like hand tomorrow ditch Danny G
Colin thank you have a good day and he
goes not icon and you gotta go how BIG's
your dad how big your dad 6-4 to 40 you
know like big dude were you at this time
I always probably six to 185 I know not
having missed too much school
I'm not gonna call and I know just
caught everyone's doing it like I'm
gonna graduate I'm gonna call it you
gives a [ __ ] and he was what you say
gives up I don't kiss him and I go who
gives a [ __ ] and he goes excuse me I
went you know what
and my parents are divorced I mean [ __ ]
could also my mom do it no no I just
turn around hurts on small it's pretty
quiet and yeah I just and then it starts
picked up and then he had a pen and he
[ __ ] Chuck this pen it's like stitch
in the necklace in G it's the walls like
let me tell you okay I was like well
look same of school won't do that again
my bad my bad next we do that even
though I'm out of school you know what
forget it I'm gonna come back oh we're
gonna do the same thing next year I just
needed those reality checks man
my oldest brother I remember the day he
challenged my dad nobody it looks oh oh
he was probably 14 at the time and I was
like six right and me and my other two
brothers are playing in my room and my
brother comes in and he just stands in
the doorway and he goes I'm fighting dad
today
and we were like what you're doing what
and he was like
Hermey I'm fighting dad today and he was
like you guys got my back and we didn't
not gonna jump our dad but no but we
also look if there's gonna be a
revolution you want to be on the right
side of that Jeff do you know what I
mean like you don't you have to pick
sides and since this larger man was
standing in front of us at the time we
got you bro yeah we had to pick you guys
ready really we're ready and he stood
cuz she started going there's gonna be
some new rules I'm like [ __ ] no rules
yeah he was like whenever not a big like
he had us Lord of the Flies pumped up
like grabbing pictures of my dad off the
wall [ __ ] [ __ ] this dude so we're
running outside right he goes he's out
back let's go so we go out back and my
dad's sitting in the back and he's
smoking a cigar and my brother walks out
and the three of us are behind him and
he goes we're fighting today old man and
my dad goes okay and he stands up my
brother okay my brother goes you do the
old man said oh he didn't he didn't he
did the old man noise he was like I'm
about to whoop that ass and he gets up
and my brother goes and let me tell you
something and before my brother could
say anything else my dad kicked him in
the nuts
so hardly dude [ __ ] dropped in prison
rule like a stone prison world rules at
the wolf house he said to my brother he
goes first of all don't talk when you
fight Jesus Christ and he goes licks of
the three of us he was you guys got
anything to say and by the way you know
how I know that you know how I knew he
was gonna win cuz my dad didn't take the
cigar out of his mouth like how
confident he was he was like [ __ ] kid
I feel pretty good or what the funny
though is the stories rush in there's
people that's trying I go I beat the
[ __ ] out of my dad yeah yeah yeah I
can't really tell my stood up dad knock
- yeah like there's someone out there
I'm sure there's a lot of video like
someone out there like Romero big and
tough dad was when I turned 17 I beat
the [ __ ] up yeah what do you do if
you're the dad no I kept eating your ass
was dead next day like oh yeah I asked
what do you do know I asked a guy on my
show cuz I used to tell this story on
stage and a guy and I asked her who else
fought their dad and one guy goes yeah I
beat him I'd be my dad when I was 16 I
go what happened he throw you out and he
goes yeah he threw me out the next day
and everybody I've talked to
wanna throw him out throw him out the
alpha-male he said you know what [ __ ] if
you can't handle on your own why do you
need me
also dude if he's kicking your ivories
right telling him to take out the trash
she's gonna be like eat dicks man you
take out the trash like fair point yes
we pay the bill
no what are you doing your wife is in
front of your wife 16 year old just
ragdoll you're a goddamn liar girl in a
tough move some way I would have to wait
till he went to sleep and just get real
diabolic I'll just make a lot of excuses
wait
I've ejected this is [ __ ] you know I
wasn't ready and then just catch him off
guard yeah when he some time now yeah
dude I I don't think that I would have
been able to handle it if my son had
beat me and if he had been smarter he
could have beat me if he was training on
the side like doing jujitsu and bike box
then we're doing some [ __ ] and then you
go to you know I do let's do this thing
just beats the [ __ ] out of you it would
have been a great story yeah I don't
think it would have been great for the
house that's the hilarious concept cuz
you're in you're special it's all about
this and at the end we can see it yeah
yeah yeah this special is basically tell
people really you smashed on my website
comedian Josh wolf calm but like if you
like storytelling it there's no politics
I hope you're not watching this special
to learn anything is not that kind of
special right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]